What I want to do is define a function, and let's call it n_ary,
and it takes (f), which should be a binary function, that is a function that takes
exactly 2 arguments,
and n_ary should return a new function that can take any number of arguments.
We'll call this one f2, so that f2 of (a, b, c) is = f(a, f(b, c)),
and that will be true for any number of arguments--2 or more.
It doesn't have to just be a, b, c.
So let's see if you can write this function n_ary.
Here's a description of what it should do.
It takes a binary function (f) as input, and it should return this n_ary function,
that when given more than 2 arguments returns this composition of arguments.
When given 2 arguments, it should return exactly what (f) returns.
We should also allow it to take a single argument and return just that argument.
That makes sense for a lot of functions (f), say for sequence.
The sequence of 1 item is the item.
For alt, the alternative of 1 item is the item.
I mentioned addition and multiplication makes sense to say the addition of a number
by itself is that number or same with multiplication.
So that's a nice extension for n_ary.
See if you can put your code here.
So what we're doing is, we're passed in a function.
We're defining this new n_ary function, putting the code in there,
and then we're returning that n_ary function as the value of that call.